you were talking uh we're talking a
little bit off camera just kind of about
like uh Mexicans and Hip-Hop yeah and uh
obviously there's I feel like um
the landscape of Mexican hip-hop isn't
the best place it's ever been yeah for
sure hell yeah um yeah because I've seen
both eras you know right I was like I
remember like when I first like
obviously growing up in Arizona we have
MC Magic we go to the low rider show it
was always at them off of Tucson yeah we
were doing all them shows [ __ ] high
power records yeah I was on stage with
them and uh and uh you know little Rob
and [ __ ] brown boy and all these guys
shout a little Uno all these guys and uh
it was big over there it was huge but it
was like an extreme it was it was
literal Chicano rap hell yeah and it was
packed thousands of people thousands
hell yeah right and so like it was like
I always would like Little Rob I think
was probably one of the only
quote-unquote Chicano rappers because I
don't consider MC Magic that because I
think he just makes love music that
[ __ ] love
um yeah he's he's auto-tune singer
before auto-tune singers were popular
right he's a voice box guy yeah after
Roger Troutman
um but little Rob had like records that
we played on the radio like hits you
know what I mean Around the Clock yeah
and so
um after him I felt like
uh there was a few records Big Gemini
had a cool joint um but I felt like
there's kind of been like once that era
kind of dried out
it was kind of like dry I feel like
commercially for a lot of Mexican
hip-hop and now I mean look we talked
about King Lil G kind of held that flag
first a long time now there's so many
artists yes
um there's artists like a guy like cap G
yeah you know there's a guy who's from
Atlanta
um there's suede there's
pesos
there's so many dark skin OT there's
[ __ ] Mexican OT from Houston Man
Gangnam like we're killing it dog but
what's always happening with us is this
bro like we're misrepresented either in
the business side right or or were
misrepresented on the streets you feel
what I'm saying and what I mean by like
the first era we're talking about Lil
Robin on them right it was exploited the
cholo whole look was exploited to you
couldn't [ __ ] even sell it no more
like Kosh was giving out deals to just
anybody you know what I mean so you
would go to that's where you got your
deal right yeah so you would go to
Target [ __ ] that was like 50 different
Mexican cholos on the shelves like you
didn't even know what to pick up and it
wasn't based on Talent they were just
giving deals on looks because they don't
they don't they didn't know how to
calibrate our talent right or what we
like you know what I'm saying
um
so then that happened the oversaturation
of the cholo cholo cholo to where it
ended up becoming almost like a mockery
you feel I'm saying it became it became
a joke you know what I'm saying um
because we evolved in the streets but as
far as like on the covers of CDs and
music we weren't right right because
they weren't letting no Talent new
talent in you feel insane because all
them cholos that they signed a lot of
them were hating on the rest you gotta
understand at that era we were still set
tripping on each other like crazy so
there was a lot of Street politics I
wasn't allow oh homie's dog but he from
18 we can't [ __ ] with him our homies
from White fans we can't [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying like there was a lot of
that going on
that's the biggest change that I noticed
this time I came home like the set
tripping amongst us in the business
wasn't as big but then what I saw was
this like
we had such a complex
from sounding like Chicano rappers that
at this point we became the exploiters
of the Black Culture by trying to sound
too black you know what I'm saying so
it's like like Nipsey said in the album
you get abused long enough you become
the abuser we start abusing the game you
feel what I'm saying now
we're looking for an identity and yeah
there's a gang of homies with Talent
right coming up coming up coming up [ __ ]
shout out to burner too yeah I mean to
be honest berner's probably the most
yeah successful Mexican rappers yeah
yeah I mean [ __ ]
um so yeah so now you got at this point
right and the little homies
are being raised by IG right and what
does IG mainly put out there like the
Black Culture they're exploit I just
exploring the [ __ ] of the Black Culture
to the fullest extent yeah without Black
Culture all these social media platforms
ain't [ __ ] would be you know but they're
exploiting them in the wrong way to me I
think you know I'm saying there is no
highlighting educated black man there is
no highlighting men black men that raise
families that are pillars in their
Community you know what I'm saying the
ones that do they're getting laid out
every single one is getting laid out you
know I mean like smoke you know yeah the
[ __ ] that goes viral is always the [ __ ]
that's like okay we get it like some of
these Instagram Pages really just focus
on like
the drama the craziest [ __ ] dog and what
it and what they don't realize is that
social media is Raising this next
Generation right you feel I'm saying
literally their rate they're raising the
youth you know because they have more
influence from the phone than even their
own parents right you know what I'm
saying
um so now that's where we're at and I
was just having this conversation
earlier with drummer boy shout out
drummer boy he's another one you know I
have to far from this [ __ ] he's from uh
Pomona yeah yeah so the homie's telling
me like he he literally asked me the
same [ __ ] but a different context he's
like how do you feel about where we're
at right now and I'm like dog like right
now we gotta fight for identity as a
culture because if we don't
what's going to happen is we're going to
be coming to Houston
and and I don't mean that and no
disrespectful way but the Hispanics in
Houston
have adapted the Black Culture
completely to where you can't really
tell the difference between
a Mexican rapper and a black rapper do
you think it's
a subject matter thing I know I just
think that I just think that
man you don't really want to know what I
think dog cause it's gonna sound ugly
yeah but I think it comes with a type of
submission bro you know what I'm saying
like they gave up on trying to represent
the culture in its purest form you know
what I mean so they just kind of like
you know what this is how we gonna get
on
like I could I could I could easily say
the n-word in every song right now right
and I'll probably do better numbers
I could probably go braids in my dog and
start doing you know what I'm saying
like
because that's where we're at right now
you know I'm saying everybody imitating
the Black Culture right without no
regard for their culture no regard for
their lineage no regard for their blood
and no regard for their history yeah I
think like it also depends on where you
were raised because I look at a guy like
that's [ __ ] no no no listen but
listen I was gonna say I look at a guy
like Captain in certain I look like a
guy like cap G who's never I've never
heard him say the N word yeah yeah when
you listen to cap G he was raised in
Atlanta right yeah so like a lot of his
music sounds like Atlanta you know what
I'm saying but then he'll have other
records that have a lot of heavily like
he has a day without a Mexican which was
a [ __ ] Banger so I think cap G has
done a really good job of like balancing
them I'm a dude who grew up where I grew
up I'm from Atlanta which is like yeah
in my opinion the capital of like
hip-hop culture now you know yeah most
definitely yeah I think cap G has done a
great job of life so then why don't we
see a lot more blacks trying to be
Mexican that grew up that grew up around
Mexicans
I don't I mean [ __ ] okay that's the
proof in the pudding to me you feel what
I'm saying it's like what's the biggest
form of humility
imitation yeah okay then you feel what
I'm saying and I'm not I mean and hey
well listen listen talk to me let's go
there have been a lot of artists I hate
to beat the tiger horse dead yeah but
listen but they but they the way they do
it is very strategically Smart Bro and
then I know YG just put a record out
with cucko yeah so like I think that
there has been and I think that like
but it's a small [ __ ] number true but
those guys grew up in La yeah YG signed
uh Savoy Loco you know why do dresses
like us for the most part he's got the
Stacy Adams he's got the last of his
head his whole [ __ ] everything like the
homies I think I think YG has been
somebody who obviously grew up around
Mexicans and in my opinion at least yeah
has paid homage Tastefully hell yeah I
think look honestly for whatever people
say about YG how they say it like I
think that he comes off sincere when he
feels like he has sincere love that's
what I'm saying like of course like
tiger [ __ ] I'm sorry that didn't come
off sincere at all you know I mean that
was like it would and listen all much
love to that and that [ __ ] is old as
[ __ ] yeah he took the video down yeah
it's great like all up to him at the
table you know cool but it did it didn't
come up it came off it didn't come off
whoever was behind him right failed
right right you know what I'm saying but
you know like I'm that's just the way I
see it you know what I'm saying like
that's the way I see it and um it's
about to do another shift like it's
about to do another shift like if you
hit the block right now there's no more
skinny jeans duh the little homies are
dressing like me now again right yt's
and 501s all day I think well I think
two the other thing we got to talk about
is like obviously hip-hop is Black
Culture first most definitely so I think
well I would say that it's white and
black culture I think it's black and I I
know a lot of people and Puerto Ricans
black nah I'm gonna tell you why I say
that though why do you say why Beastie
Boys is [ __ ] you mean one of the first
hip-hop groups ever yeah but the first
no you're right you're right you're
right wrong but that was like 84. I
understand it wasn't like at the roots
but I'm saying when it mattered
come on it was a bunch of white boys
from right here I think I think it's
you know if we go back to like you know
79 80 81 and Puerto Ricans and black
yeah you know what I mean it came for
sure over there yeah the mecca right
like right hell yeah most definitely but
when it took the stage and it was really
time to make it a business
it was the Beastie Boys and it was all
cool Hello Cool J Beastie Boys Grand
Master Flash right yeah see what I'm
saying so you know I mean
that's not how I feel I'm just going by
what I saw growing up because I'm a huge
hip-hop fan you know what I'm saying but
um but there's beef over that too like
people like man who gives a [ __ ] dog I
believe like look dog
how do you create something there's the
people that build it and there's the
people that fund the building we funded
the building so how are we not a part of
it if we didn't believe in it and push
hip-hop the creation of it and stand
behind it it would have never took off
the way it did I mean and I mean all of
us I think but I think like the answer
to what you were asking like why don't
people imitating what we're doing I
think if you like one black culture is
the number one most influential culture
in in the US yeah yeah and you could say
it has been Asia everywhere in the world
hell yeah and Hip-Hop culture hip hop is
the number one genre of music in the
world that's that's a fact a fact so
hip-hop's the number one genre of music
and it's it's it's derived from Black
Culture it is it is Black Culture you
know what I'm saying so I think that
that and black culture is the most
influential culture in the country
period like that's no debate yeah no
debate yeah like fashion you go to h m
you go that's all right yeah 100 so I
think that that's probably a little bit
more closer to like why you were it's
like yeah well why is nobody imitating
what we're doing and I do think that
obviously like there's very small
examples where people okay how much I
hear that part of the argument and I've
thought about that part of the argument
okay but then when I see rap videos
low riders well especially on the west
coast you know what I was going to say
would you consider I mean because to me
no writing is us that's us 100 oh yeah
but you think about you know Dr Dre
Snoop Dogg oh hell yeah they adopted him
100 yeah but they did it right though
we didn't say that they did it in a way
that they paid homage hell yeah they did
a cloud they did it with class yeah you
know what I'm saying they they
represented they they they because
really low riders is is is is obviously
a Mexican thing but it's a la thing it's
La thing yeah yeah start on the east
side yeah yeah but um I think that the
way they did it was um they showed like
the the the the parts they should
highlight like the dope [ __ ] that we do
you know what I'm saying nah you know
goofy [ __ ] you know what I'm saying or
[ __ ] dressed like Mariachis
like we don't we're not out here
dressing like we're out you know what
I'm saying like I mean let's just be
real you feel I'm saying I get it's a
part of the culture huge part of culture
but I never seen one of my homies on the
Block dressed like a mariachi Mariachi
say it right like I'm talking like you
know I mean like I don't know no better
but you know what I'm saying so I mean I
don't know I'm I'm just a person that
goes by facts and I like I like honesty
so I'm saying so if I'm gonna be honest
like I see a lot of [ __ ] that um that
isn't necessarily fair but it is what it
is dog like at this point
um you know we're either gonna where
they're gonna rise from this with our
own Foundation our own structure or
we're just gonna become a part of the
rest of the machine you know what I'm
saying so it's on us I think at that
part and that's what I was talking to
Drummer Boy about like I told him like
look bro like this is your time like
what you guys do at this moment is going
to Define
our people in the game for a while you
know I mean because right now like as a
people in this music game we're
searching for an identity you know what
I'm saying we really are like I was
talking to him earlier about the way
that he creates music you know and I was
telling him the same [ __ ] like bro if
you look different and you're a
different ethnicity you should be
through the roof right now bro yeah but
you got to fight the stigma you know
what I'm saying so do you fight the
stigma do you because hip-hop don't love
us for whatever it's worth we love
hip-hop but hip-hop don't love us at all
you know what I'm saying so are you
gonna stay in a toxic relationship or
are you going to move on and find a new
Breezy and make your family you know you
know what I really think it is man I
think
there has to be an honest conversation
where we're like who's the who's the
Mexican rapper that you feel like
was on the same level as Drake or Jay-Z
or there hasn't been one ever so that's
what I'm saying that's gonna take that
guy but why though hasn't there been one
I mean it's gonna take that guy in the
past yeah where you're like there's
somebody that's so dope it's undeniable
yeah so to me it's like there's been a
lot of cool like cool dope Mexican
artists but has there been one that's so
crazy that that it's just undeniable
whether it's
ability look at the one that they hit
records the one that they did blow up
for who no Talent on I mean six nine bro
the one that they did blow up like come
on bro like okay okay so so and I don't
want to get into this Mission thing
because that's been yeah that's besides
six nine yeah yeah had records
he had undeniable records okay so it
didn't matter if he was like very
deniable how come La wasn't jamming them
all crazy in the clubs they were the
clubs isn't the streets though bro yeah
the club is one stream I'm talking about
I'm talking about 2018
dropped who wasn't playing that [ __ ] on
the Block everybody okay then let's go
more relevant when um YG dropped My
Crazy Life who in the [ __ ] wasn't
playing that [ __ ] out here everybody
everybody everybody that's everywhere
because I travel everywhere people are
playing all right six nine wasn't
booming like that I don't know man I
think a lot of those numbers see to me
the six nine [ __ ] was to me a perfect
example of somebody who just made
records that like were kind of
undeniable so it didn't really matter
that he was a clown and this is before
he snitched yeah of course yeah when
this [ __ ] was moving and we had that
conversation where I was like
artists gotta like
happen to be Mexican but be dope first
yeah and I think six nine
six nine yeah people were like oh he's
got some gumbo and all that [ __ ] was for
them shits were hard the Nikki record
was hard and he happened to be a Mexican
guy yeah does that make sense yeah it
does yeah it does so I think like he had
records what was he but was he we're
under I think he had no but was he
represent the culture
I think he would representing his
culture how he grew up maybe does that
make sense I don't know yeah I could be
I don't know yeah you know what I'm
saying but
[ __ ] I think that I think I think that
that but that's an example of what I was
saying like yeah Who's the artist that
like is making undeniable hit records or
is just so crazy that it's like yo this
[ __ ] King Lil G broke through
right right and he's selling out shows
all over the nation yeah he was on
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] was there no love
because he represented me and how I look
that's fair you understand what I'm
saying like the homie look at stole the
product that girl you know the product
she does shows everywhere does it she's
still not good she just got nominated
for a Latin Grammy well thank God for
her God hey and snow is the you know
she's a god level MC for sure okay so
that's what I'm saying like why why why
I don't know no the little girl Munch
just took off [ __ ] I don't know where
one Snow's never had one of those
records though what the [ __ ] and
everybody's flying around no I'm just
speaking facts you know I mean can Munch
this much that and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
like the track isn't that hard I mean
it's cool but you know it's a Tick-Tock
thing yeah but you guys know the product
slaughtering [ __ ] like I mean [ __ ] come
on bro like this snow is slaughtering
[ __ ] in her world in the same way that
like
think of tech Nine tech nine can wrap
his [ __ ] ass off I think she's more
dimensional than him oh of course
because she's she's I heard
um radio please that's not a direct like
correlation to their followings or their
music I see what you're saying you know
what I'm saying so I just think that
like yeah man I think I think that with
everything we've talked about what we
can both agree on is that it's all going
in a positive direction well yeah any
any any [ __ ] momentum is good I mean
look money sign swage it has a deal with
Atlantic Records oh yeah I mean cat G
was on Atlantic he's about to drop a
record with Jay Balvin you know you got
homies like me running around tearing
[ __ ] up man apparently 100 on their own
I'm doing features [ __ ] I
shouldn't be doing them yeah but I
couldn't do them 15 years ago
[ __ ] just